this twisted version of the children's  game is just as nerve-inducing in the  studio surrounded by blue screen we can  see the intense energy coming through  luckily when number 456 fell he had a  softer landing than what we see  the death-defying height may not have  been real but all the energy and sweat  during the tug of war definitely was  every actor is fully committed the scene  still looks terrifying even on a shorter  platform making sure dangerous scenes  could be filmed safely was super  important and while we see the actors  are taken care of it's still a high  tension moment behind the scenes as  performers act out falling through glass  unexpectedly the cgi fully convinces us  that the actors really fall down to  their end the cgi environment really  completes the look for the final battle  the footage and performances are totally  raw no one on the squid game team held  back